deuxième candidat première prise mazel
la 7e tandis date vous appeler anne
marie peysson vous avez là j'ai 22 ans
et votre profession je suis depuis trois
ans pékin la télé marseille la maison
des risques
bon quel est notre formation scolaire où
je me suis arrêté à la première partie
du bachot parce que je suis entré à la
télévision à ce moment là bon vous
parler des langues étrangères l'anglais
est un petit peu l'espagnol l'anglais
pas mal et en angleterre
c'est drôle ça coûte à leur mercie
voulez vous mettre dans très lentement
tourner la tête sur la gauche de façon
de présenter votre profil droit martyrs
étendard et permet la bouche
revenez vers nous le joli sourire au
passage voilà de l'autre côté c'est ça
revenez bond la deuxième épreuve dont
mademoiselle on vous a donné à une
vingtaine de minutes un texte avant par
kirk et le programme éthique d'une
journée de télévision vous les voyez le
daily mail
bonjour chers amis et bien dans quelques
instants nous retrouverons jacques schab
années roger ferrals qui nous attendent
au barde téléparis comme chaque jour et
leur émission sera suivie à 13h15 de
dernière heure et du journal télévisé la
troisième diffusion du journal télévisé
mais si vous voulez bien auparavant
nous allons jeter un petit coup d'oeil
sur ce que sera le programme de cette
journée
tout d'abord cet après midi de 14h à
14h30
l'émission scolaire on y parlera
aujourd'hui du costume civil et
militaire à rome le programme de la
soirée commencera à 19h30 avec économie
et industrie une émission de nice joyeux
lavergne et charles corrèze réalisé par
solange peters à 20h fidèles j'ai
consacré aux pêcheurs roulante et à 20h
fidèles du feuilleton vous retrouverez
votre héros le colonel march et au cours
de ce nouvel épisode
je pense qu'il vous fera encore les
témoins de sa de son flair infaillible à
20h40 nous nous rendrons à londres pour
retrouver jacques salbert qui pendant
quelques minutes qui nous entretiendra
et à 20h50 nous reviendrons dans nos
studios
d'où nous vous présenterons une pièce de
somerset maugham adapté pour la
télévision par jacques chabane la lettre
c'est une réalisation de jean paul
carrère à 22h10 nous avons un rendez
vous avec jacqueline joubert qui elle
même en a fixé à à jacques brel et enfin
à 22 heures avec alexandre tartas j'ai
oublié et à 22h40
raymond thevenaz au cours de sa tribune
nous parlera de la circulation nous en
exposera tous les problèmes c'est tout
un programme je crois n'oublions pas à
20h15 et en fin de soirée les dernières
heures et le journal télévisé d'une
circulation
j'ai passé les gants dit et c'est
terminé on pas dire à télé paris 7eme
candidate troisième prise
loiselle cresson on vous a donné des
éléments de l'annonce pour la grande
édition du soir que vous avez pu
apprendre soit parker soit tourné à
votre façon à votre idée voulez vous
nous annoncer sa démission
et maintenant place au théâtre c'est une
oeuvre de somerset mogan que jacques
chabal a adapté pour la télévision que
nous vous proposons de regarder ce soir
réalisé dans nos studios par jean paul
carrère ce drame car il s'agit d'un
gramme a pour cadre une île de la
malaisie
il a pour sujet un cas est étonnant de
dissimulation féminine et il est mené un
petit peu à la façon d'une pièce
policière
mais je laisse à l'adaptateur jacques
chavanne le soin de vous présenter mieux
que moi oeuvre et interprète
merci septième candidat quatrième
épreuve
pour mademoiselle il y a deux minutes
on vous a appris que l'émission prévue
pour ce soir de couverts jean lieu pour
une cause indépendante de volontaires
vous attendez tous les éléments de cette
annonce vous voulez vous improvisez
votre annonce d' excuses eh bien nous
devons ce soir vous présentez transmis
depuis le studio une pièce de somerset
maugham adapté pour la télévision par
jacques chabal il s'agissait de la
lettre malheureusement l'interprète
principale vient de tomber malade et
nous nous trouvons dans l'obligation de
ne pas vous présenter cette émission
nous espérons que vous voudrez bien nous
en excuser et nous vous proposons en
remplacement un grand film il s'agit
d'un western c'est à dire que grands et
petits ils trouveront certainement
beaucoup de plaisir et vous pourrez
entendre siffler l'assaut vous pourrez
assister un nombre de bagarres
je crois que vous vous amuserez beaucoup
voici terreur en oklahoma c'était
m'avait dit à l'heure vous avez appris
un peu l'anglais est un peu d'espagnol
voulez-vous me dire en anglais ce que
l'on voit sur tout et partir de wagons
il est dangereux de se pencher is
dangerous to line out bon et en espagnol
voulez-vous me dire colomb de mon coeur
à l'armada l'allemagne pas l'homme à del
alma mia on doit le foie pas l'homme
adalah le mamiya c'est sa merci le
septième candidat cinquième épreuve non
le détour avec vous asseoir à bouger
plus ouvrier c'est très bien